your daughter is named Wyatt which is a
very cool name are you gonna go it with
a unique name for your son we have a
name dialed in that we've had for a
while but you know the problem is if you
get the name too soon suddenly there's
like could be like there's like slight
trepidation around the name and so like
the other day Mila was like so what you
you know you still like the name and I
was like yeah and she's like what was
why was that why was it the high-pitch
yeah like why wasn't it the low-pitch
yeah and then we were like why and I was
like you like the name right she's like
yeah and I'm like wait why did you say
like that and so now we're like maybe we
don't like the name even though we both
love the name right so I think we have a
name was there a name that you came up
with but it got nixed that you think
yeah cool I had I there was a rallying
cry from a collective that believed in
the name Hawkeye it's like mash like he
could be a doctor yeah cuz one mash well
hot guys got so many great it's just
such a great cool name guy thank you
Jeff okay yeah didn't fly no didn't get
across the Mila threshold no it like
came to the threshold but then it got
knocked down the big problem I found my
wife when I found this I don't know if
you experienced a sandy but is you come
up one of the people in the couple comes
up with a name and it's a really good
name and the other one says like I had a
really good name I like the name miles
and my wife is like I knew a miles he
was an but that's a really like
the real thing that is a real thing yeah
you don't want like names of people that
remind you of people that used to beat
you up yeah that's not good no but I was
wondering if it's a really good name and
she's like yeah he was worked at a
checkout counter and he you know we
always put the fruit at the bottom it's
out it's like no that's not a good
enough reason yeah that's not a good
enough reason yeah yeah it's got it has
to be like some egregious thing where
like they were really a jerk yeah like
they murdered that to me is you don't
never you know son after a murderer or
people to beat up babies yeah this is no
children
P goes around beating up baby some there
are some people apparently that do that
no one does that there's no one around
it's like give me a baby out where are
you baby I'll fight any baby in this
afar
you